j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
vous le savez le plus souvent possible
dans le décale volontairement de
l'actualité du jour il porte ce soir sur
un phénomène qui prend l'ampleur les
complotistes du climat ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux en France à remettre en
cause la réalité scientifique du
réchauffement climatique avant d'en
débattre on décortique leur discours
leur stratégie avec Flora sauvage
moyen
entraîner le monde dans leur chute et
c'est pour ça il faut vous mentir sur la
météo il le feront donc voilà alors on a
l'Italie qui est sous les eaux là ici
dans le Massif Central ça fait 15 jours
que il tombe des de la flotte de la
flotte de la flotte mais on est en
sécheresse moi je me demande si tout ça
c'est pas fait pour mettre encore de
nouvelles taxes ce genre de message
pullule sur les réseaux sociaux depuis
la canicule de l'été 2022 les
climato-sceptiques ou climatoignaliste
ont envahi la toile Julien Poncet a
réalisé une note pour la Fondation Jean
Jaurès sur ceux qui se définissent sur
Twitter comme des climato réalistes
majoritairement
issus de la sphère antivaces et pro
Poutine on a tout un discours centré
autour de la question des libertés qui
fait éruption dans le débat autour de
concepts très marketé dictature
climatique passe climatique qui viennent
interférer avec la question climatique
et postuler en réalité que la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique est
une opportunité pour les gouvernements
et la montée en puissance des climatos
complotistes sur la toile a des
conséquences directes sur l'opinion des
Français des éléments de langage qui ne
transitent pas dans l'espace public
normal quand ils sont testés sur les
Français en réalité le fonctionnement
exemple dictature climatique un une
expression disons assez radicale quand
elle est testée en population française
elle à peu près 40% des Français
adhèrent à l'idée qu'effectivement dans
le cadre de la lutte climatique
une dictature est en train de se
profiler face à la résurgence des
discours complotistes sur Twitter ce
climatologue reste pourtant optimiste ça
fait très longtemps que je lutte contre
les climatosceptiques et il faut
rappeler que la situation aujourd'hui
elle est bien meilleure que ce qu'elle
était il y a 15 ans c'est à dire que il
y a 15 ans dans les émissions de grands
au grand public dans les dans les médias
traditionnels on voyait encore beaucoup
de climatos des nialistes en fait
les vins son tour tuyaux les gens comme
ça c'est terminé ça il faut bien
reconnaître que dans les grands médias
il n'y a plus de climatosceptique
climatoignaliste malgré la hausse des
phénomènes extrêmes le dérèglement
climatique semble devenir le nouveau
terrain de jeu pour les complotistes sur
les réseaux sociaux une remise en cause
permanente bien loin du
climatocepticisme qui existait il y a
encore quelques années qui sont les
complotistes du climat comment les
contrer en en débat avec Magalie riazza
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes géographe
membre du Haut Conseil pour le climat
Victor schumel bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes docteur en sciences sociales
chercheurs associés au CNRS et auteur
d'une thèse sur la désinformation Fred
pour un bonsoir bienvenue journaliste
fondateur de la plateforme l'esprit
sorcier Mathieu croissanto évidemment
est resté à mes côtés éditoris politique
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord sur le
Conseil
un climatologue qui disait finalement
c'est un peu moins grave qu'il y a
quelques quelques années parce que ce
discours il est moins dans l'espace
grand public tout ce qui est c'est ce
que vous ressentez magaliotta alors je
suis mal placée parce que d'une certaine
façon quand on travaille en permanence
sur le climat en fait on est
effectivement de tout le temps attaquer
par ça alors effectivement
j'aime pas le mot de complotisme parce
qu'effectivement là aussi c'est du méta
complot mais effectivement on voit qu'on
est souvent attaqué notamment les
chercheurs alors ça va soit sur des
attaques vous êtes des militants comme
si d'ailleurs être militant c'était une
insulte c'est d'ailleurs drôle parce que
c'est souvent des gens de partis
politiques qui eux-mêmes ont des
militants donc c'est pas très cohérent
souvent aussi ce que vous dites c'était
une opinion alors c'est un fait vous
êtes une scientifique qui vous le défait
donc quand on regarde après les grandes
enquêtes ça dépend en fait ce qu'on
regarde mais je pense qu'il y a des
personnes ici mieux placées pour en
parler on voit un double mouvement c'est
que d'un côté globalement quand même on
recule cette idée que le changement
climatique est là
une fois qu'on va dans le détail c'est
un peu plus compliqué est-ce qu'il est
d'origine humaine 50 100% et entre les
qu’est ce qui se passe donc c'est pas
très simple quand on regarde par contre
les enquêtes d'opinion chez les élus
alors là on est beaucoup moins bon que
sur la majorité de la fin sur la
population globale plus largement je
pense que pour les chercheurs c'est
c'est extrêmement violent parce que un
chercheur a priori il est là pour
chercher et quand il fait ce travail de
diffusion de la connaissance qui fait
aussi partie de ses missions les
attaques personnelles les attaques en
permanence sur son travail c'est très
violent et ça décourage beaucoup en
réalité de d'y aller quoi Victor Schum
un peu de sémantique quel mot vous
employez déjà est-ce que vous dites
climato complotistes climato-sceptique
est-ce que le mot complotiste du climat
vous l'acceptez ou pas alors je suis
assez d'accord je vais vous montrer le
même point effectivement
beaucoup globalement quelque chose de
différent et qui en général ne permet
pas de lancer le débat quand ça reste à
quelqu'un le de complotistes entre
guillemets on sait très bien qu'on va
couper dès le début d'échange
le nouveau terrain des complotistes ceux
qui sont sensibles à ça ils sont déjà
partis quoi ok
c'est alors justement le but c'est
d'éviter de parler par exemple de climat
aussi notamment un peu pour les mêmes
raisons avec l'idée que aujourd'hui on
est plus face à un doute on est plus un
scepticisme qui serait entre guillemets
scientifique on est dans du déni on sait
qu'aujourd'hui ça fait plus de 10 ans ça
fait 20 ans ça fait 30 ans etc on
travaille sur ces sujets là des
scientifiques sont aujourd'hui unanime
on a tous les rapports du chèque et on
sait que si on a un consensus et qu'on a
des personnes en face ces personnes là
sont dans le déni vis-à-vis de se
consensus
donc on parle plutôt de climato dédié
pour parler de ces personnes là d'accord
et donc on est bien loin de l'esprit un
peu scientifique donc parfois il se
réclame
frais de courts c'est je sais pas quel
terme employé je vais continuer de dire
complotiste du climat excusez-moi mais
c'est quoi ça ça vient c'est un discours
qui vient aux États-Unis ils ont des
motivations aussi parfois politiques
parfois économique comment vous les
décrivez vous oui il y a des motivations
très c'est très hétérogène en fait on
sait pas pourquoi certains d'ailleurs
ils se contredisent entre eux souvent
sur sur les réseaux sociaux bah il y a
des motifs économiques je sais pas si
ils existent encore profondément mais on
sait très bien que dans les années 80-90
les grandes compagnies pétrolières
payaient des gens créent des comptes
pour pour faire de la désinformation
pour semer le doute pour semer le doute
bien évidemment et puis il y a des
motivations manifestement politique
voire géopolitique puisqu'on sait très
bien qu'il y a des comptes qui doivent
être créés aussi dans des pays étrangers
pour pas les citer en Russie pour
pouvoir quelque part déstabiliser
l'opinion donc il y a des motivations
qui sont qui sont très différentes les
unes des autres mais ce qu'il faut bien
voir c'est que il y a pas de débat il y
a pas de controverse climatique en
réalité c'est totalement faux de dire ça
il y a un large consensus pour dire bah
oui il y a un réchauffement climatique
sauf que bon on les appelle les
complotistes alors et bien sont là pour
dire mais il faut un débat alors que
leurs arguments ont largement et depuis
pas mal de temps étaient démontés par
par les vrais scientifiques oui mais moi
je enfin j'ai souvent des discussions
avec des proches dans différents milieux
qui par exemple disent mais qu'est-ce
que c'est le GIEC qu'est-ce qui nous
prouve que le GIEC c'est vraiment des
scientifiques d'où ils viennent et ce
qui sont si nombreux qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent
le GIEC c'est la France déjà quand on
alors il y a des choses faciles pour les
reconnaître le GIEC c'est 195 États qui
se mettent ensemble d'accord et il
mandatent des experts scientifiques de
tous les pays qui sont des scientifiques
ou quoi qui vont faire ce qu'on appelle
une revue de littérature ils vont
regarder tout ce qui a été publié dans
le monde entier autrement dit quand on a
le rapport du GIEC on a un résumé au
décideur qui est accepté mot par mot par
les États ça veut dire que l'Arabie
Saoudite ça veut dire que la France ça
veut dire que dans les 195 pays alins
qui disent je veux pas le mot ne figure
pas 1 2 les experts du GIEC je dis bien
les experts sont bénévoles
bénévole et 3 les experts du GIEC ne
prescrivent rien ne recommande rien et
ce qu'a dit Fred courant c'est très
intéressant on ne débat pas d'un fait
scientifique
ce n'est pas une opinion
sceptique sur ce plateau parce que ça
fait 4 vous faites pas des débats sur la
terre tourne autour du soleil parce que
même si on n'était pas d'accord autour
de ça comme disait l'autre vous savez
Galilée là je crois que c'était lui et
pourtant elle tourne en revanche on doit
débattre effectivement sur les solutions
y compris sur la possibilité de ne pas
agir ce qui est très différent et
aujourd'hui en fait on est en train de
faire porter le débat encore pour des
raisons effectivement qui ont été
documentées par les historiens qui sont
les mêmes que celles sur le tabac qui
sont les mêmes que celles qu'on a eu sur
l'amiante qu'on a eu sur plein de choses
qu'on a fait perdre du temps pour pour
prendre les vrais décisions d'accord
à partir du moment où ça fait consensus
mais il y a toujours des gens qui
contestent les consensus ou à d'autres
explications vous prenez l'idée de la
terre il y a des gens qui croient que la
terre est plate parce que voilà le
consensus fait que tout le monde le sait
la terre est ronde mais il y a des
platistes est-ce que c'est des farfelus
ou est-ce que ce sont des lobbies alors
peut-être que Victor chômel vous vous
avez étudiés vous pouvez répondre à la
question justement sur ces questions là
en fait qu'on a observé c'est que c'est
des groupes qui vont se structurer en
fait c'est assez souvent la notion de
masse critique c'est-à-dire que si avant
on avait quelques personnes dans leur
coin on reprend l'exemple de la Terre
plate en fait aujourd'hui on se
regroupant ils atteignent une taille
suffisante pour notamment avoir une
communauté qui se structure en ligne et
par exemple nous ce qu'on a pu observer
dans notre étude c'est que avant 2022
les mouvements qui étaient plutôt climat
aussi petit coup climato dédialiste en
France était relativement peu structuré
à partir 2022 pour tout un tas de
raisons et notamment parce que certains
acteurs se sont employés à importer des
dynamiques qui sont plutôt aux
États-Unis d'habitude en fait on est
important c'est dynamiques ils ont
réussi à structurer une communauté qui
ne nulle part en fait c'est une
communauté qui existait déjà avant en
France qui vient souvent de débat sur la
vaccination qui était plutôt des
hésitants vaccinaux qui sont parfois
aussi sur les débats notamment sur la
Russie qui était plutôt pro Poutine et
qui vont essaimer d'un sujet à l'autre
donc c'est des comédiés qui viennent pas
nulle part et qui se sont structurés
dans le domaine du climat et donc c'est
à ce moment-là qu'on va avoir une
communauté climatosceptique qui va être
beaucoup plus forte en France et la
probable là-dessus c'est des communautés
qui vont être un peu plus politiques
même si elles sont parfois appuies ou en
tout cas reliées par des informations
qui est beaucoup plus économiques et en
fait dans ces cas des informations
économiques et passer d'une négation
d'échauffement du réchauffement
climatique à un attentisme c'est-à-dire
on ne va rien faire on verra bien ce qui
va se passer ensuite alors quelques
chiffres donnés par la Fondation Jean
Jaurès 62000 comptes actifs qui relaient
aujourd'hui un discours complotiste sur
le climat sur Twitter ça représente
quand même selon la Fondation plus de
10% des comptes qui parlent de climat
d'accord et alors on va rentrer un peu
dans le détail reste avec vous Victor
Schuman sur vous avez envoyé quelques
quelques exemples de tweets alors c'est
une personne
une seule à une même personne enfin en
tout cas ce n'est même compte qui qui
tweet alors on va aller voir défiler je
vais pas tous les citer parce que moi
j'avoue que ça me fait un peu mal aux
oreilles mais je commence par le GIEC le
GIEC est une machine de propagande
politique se concentrant sur un prétendu
réchauffement d'origine humaine ignore
les nuages le soleil bon ensuite il y a
le très politique GIEC n'indique aucune
preuve que le réchauffement climatique a
fait que tout provoque des événements
météorologiques extrêmes après il y a
pas d'urgence climatique de 98 à 2015 la
température n'a pas augmenté etc etc
est-ce qu'il y a un vous trouvez des
narratifs vous voyez ce que je veux dire
qui sont les mêmes qui se recoupent et
qu'on retrouve un peu dans tout ce
discours en fait systématiquement sur le
sujet on a différents narratifs qui vont
même s'opposé entre eux on va voir
l'argument il n'y a pas de réchauffement
climatique on a l'argument du lien
réchauffement climatique mais qui n'est
pas d'origine humaine elle augmente il y
a la respons climatique qui est
d'origine humaine mais entre guillemets
c'est pas une priorité et en fait on
voit bien qu'on veut pas dire à la fois
il y a un réchauffement climatique et
pas d'origine humaine il n'y a pas de
réchauffement climatique et pourtant ce
qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est qu'en
fait c'est les mêmes comptes et c'est
les mêmes commun qui partage ses
différents arguments donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est plus du tout dans une posture
qui est rationnelle on est sur des
comptes qui vont juste chercher à gagner
l'audience qui vont chercher à faire la
subversion c'est à dire à déstabiliser
pour tout simplement ralentir les
politiques publiques et créer du doute
pour amener à ce qu'on disait à des
débats pour ralentir ralentir l'action
politique vous employez le terme des
marchands de doute alors c'est pas moi
qui l'emploie c'est un terme qui a été
construit par les historiens et par les
sociologues et qui reposent aussi
derrière sur un fait dont on parle pas
qui est la confusion systématique entre
la liberté d'opinion chacun a le droit
de croire en ce qu'il veut la liberté
d'expression qui est cadrée par la loi
je ne peux pas exprimer par exemple des
racistes en France et du coup on confond
ça et au nom du pluralisme on continue
par exemple d'inviter sur des plateaux
télé des gens avec une étiquette
d'expert et qu'est-ce qui ressemble plus
à un expert qu'un autre expert bah voilà
on a vu d'ailleurs des grands
scientifiques français qui se sont
fourvoyés dans ce clip bateau-sceptique
et puis ce qui est de plus en plus
graves c'est qu'un certain nombre
d'hommes politiques et de femmes
politiques en France reprennent parfois
sans même le savoir des arguments du
climatocepticisme
la responsabilité est peut-être le
manque de formation des des politiques
mais vous avez pas les médias je
voudrais qu'on se concentre là-dessus
sur le rôle des médias la responsabilité
il y a effectivement le choix d'inviter
ou pas un auteur de livres qui est un
livre à succès mais qui est un brûlot
contre le GIEC par exemple j'ai même pas
envie de citer son nom mais bon et ça on
a des confrères qui le font ben oui il y
a des confrères qui le font mais si vous
prenez les bases du journalisme c'est
normal de donner la parole à tout le
monde donc voilà on se dit sauf que là
on est dans un cas un peu particulier
c'est pas comme on disait tout à l'heure
un débat d'opinion il y a des choses qui
ont été il y a des faits établis et il y
a des contre-vérités en face qui qui
sont apportées donc ce serait donné la
parole aux marchand de mensonges en fait
de les inviter mais en même temps vous
allez vous faire parce que vous n'avez
pas mis de personnes
climato-sceptiques autour et puis moi
j'aime pas trop ce mot climato-sceptique
parce que le scepticisme est
ça fait partie de la démarche
scientifique c'est normal qu'on soit
septique on a tous le droit d'être
sceptique mais là c'est plus du
scepticisme donc c'est du déni c'est du
déni d'accord
imaginez je vais mettre un mot
vocabulaire le mot climato dénialiste
avec vous mais bon c'est pas grave
est-ce que vous inviteriez sur votre
plateau en négationniste non voilà alors
je vais un peu loin en utilisant un mot
comme ça mais c'est quand même l'avenir
de la planète qui est en jeu ces gens là
que finalement il y ait des partisans
des platistes qui pensent que la terre
est plate je dirais c'est pas grave
c'est des farfelus ça pas beaucoup de
conséquences mais là ça a des
conséquences très importantes sur les
prises de décision des politiques faut
pas perdre de temps c'est comme la
vaccination je reste sur le le rôle des
médias d'une certaine façon avec ce pour
la tribune qui est qui a été publiée ce
4 juillet voilà l'affirmation le
réchauffement climatique est un
phénomène exagéré par les médias il y a
toujours eu des fluctuations de
température indépendantes des actions
humaines et on se trouve avec 11% des
personnes interrogées qui répondent tout
à fait d'accord 29 % plutôt d'accord 60
% pas d'accord ça fait quand même 4
français sur 10 si j'ai bien compris qui
doutent de l'origine humaine du
réchauffement là aussi c'est un fait
scientifique établi qu'est-ce alors ça
vous inspire quoi ce sondage si je peux
revoir la question parce qu'en réalité
la question elle pose problème
pour pour le coup faire des sciences
sociales la manière dont on pose des
questions
il y a toujours des fluctuations de
température indépendantes des actions
humaines la réponse est vouée
le réchauffement climatique est un
phénomène exagéré par les médias la
réponse bah ça dépend lesquels et donc
en fait je peux pas répondre à la
question parce que si je réponds à il y
a toujours des fluctuations mais oui je
suis d'accord avec la question et donc
vous voyez là aussi derrière dans la
manière de poser les questions on en
arrive à dire Cap Français sur 10 sont
climatos et piquent au dénialisme et en
revanche par exemple ça serait bien à un
moment de dire voilà est-ce que vous
êtes convaincu par exemple que le climat
se réchauffe oui ou non est-ce que vous
savez que ce climat les 10 dernières
années le réchauffement est attribué de
manière certaine à 100% aux activités
humaines c'est un fait scientifique et
le vocabulaire je pense joue vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure de dictatures on a
parlé on a beaucoup de mots sur les
dénialistes etc le scepticisme par
exemple je reviens pas ça nous sommes au
pays de Descartes le doute cartésien il
y a quand même moi quand j'étais
étudiante je faisais mes études en philo
on me disait toujours le doute c'est
génial des cartes il doute jusqu'à
lui-même c'est le doute radical mais ce
que nous disait le prof de philo c'est
que quand on traverse la rue et que le
camion il arrive on arrête de douter
parce que le camion il est là et donc on
confond ici la méthode du doute l'esprit
critique c'est-à-dire cette distance
nécessaire pour tous les citoyens pour
s'approprier la connaissance et le rôle
des médias dans leur étymologie c'est
bien de faire passer et Fred courant je
pense vous êtes l'exemple
archétypal de ce travail de médiation de
vulgarisation au sens noble du terme et
puis à côté un moment on arrête de
douter parce que soit le débat chez les
scientifiques étrangers en fait chez les
scientifiques on dit pas débat on dit
dispute
disputation alors on se tape pas dessus
mais voyez par exemple quand on dit tous
les scientifiques sont d'accord j'aime
pas ça non plus parce qu'on a
l'impression que du coup les gens
enlèvent la main ils disent alors là
c'est la majorité ça se passe pas comme
ça qu'on s'insus scientifique c'est
bizarre à expliquer et toute cette
culture scientifique là on arrive pas à
la déployer pour que les gens aussi se
repèrent pour comprendre ce que c'est
justement le doute le doute bien le
doute le doute utile le doute nécessaire
et indispensable et puis le doute qui
relève là de la fabulation et du
mensonge il faut dire les choses c'est
en mensonge alors on va prendre un
exemple intéressant et grâce à Samia de
Schir qui est avec nous dans les
coulisses de ce sens public on va parler
des mégafeux qui ont ravagé le le Canada
Samia est-ce que vous êtes prêtes oui là
voilà à peu près un peu surprise pensez
que c'était un peu plus tard mais non on
en parle maintenant on va voir comment
effectivement c'est des nialistes ont
été à l'oeuvre lors de des méga feu au
Canada racontez-nous oui plus de 8
millions d'hectares parties en fumée
depuis le début de l'année au Canada
soit l'équivalent de la moitié des
forêts françaises les scientifiques sont
appelle le réchauffement climatique
favorise ce genre d'événements extrêmes
mensonge réponse répondent les
climatosceptiques ou climato dénialistes
comme on veut les appeler et donc qui se
sont déchaînés sur les réseaux sociaux à
cette occasion d'abord Maxime Bernier
qui n'est autre qu'un ancien ministre
canadien conservateur je vais vous citer
ces propos dans un tweet qui a beaucoup
tourné je gage qu'une bonne partie des
feux de forêt ont été allumées par des
terroristes verts pour donner un coup de
pouce à leur campagne de changement
climatique l'extrême gauche est experte
pour inventer et créer des crises
qu'elle peut ensuite exploiter fin de
citation pour cet ancien ministre
canadien donc c'est mégafeux n'aurait
aucun lien avec le dérèglement
climatique puisqu'il serait provoqué par
des terroristes écologiques qui
voudraient faire croire à un
réchauffement climatique
sur des soi-disant preuve imparables
dans un autre tweet qui a beaucoup
circulé un internaute reprend une image
satellite qui permet de voir l'ensemble
des départs de feu dans une province
canadienne et il s'interroge comment
est-ce possible que tous ces feux soient
partis au même moment comme si des
Pyroman c'était coordonnées pour les
allumer en même temps il y a aussi ceux
qui accusent les autorités dans un autre
tweet qui a fait plus de 670 000 vues on
voit un hélicoptère projeté des flammes
sur une forêt canadienne là encore une
preuve soi-disant du mensonge les
autorités qui enflammeraient elles-mêmes
les forêts pour pouvoir faire croire au
réchauffement climatique il s'agit en
fait d'une technique bien connue pour
maîtriser un feu le brûlage dirigé on
brûle préventivement une zone où le feu
ne va plus trouver de combustible et
donc ça peut aider à empêcher le feu de
progresser voilà Thomas un échantillon
même si j'ai trouvé beaucoup d'autres
théories assez fantaisistes que j'ai pu
lire sur les réseaux sociaux canadiens
et qui sont donc alimentés par ceux qui
s'appellent eux-mêmes des
climato-réalistes merci beaucoup Samia
de chia je voudrais
en écoutant Samia et est-ce que ceux qui
sont les les professionnels de la
récupération et de et de la
désinformation vont pas par exemple
utiliser cette chronique en prendre un
tout petit extrait sur un média sérieux
comme Public Sénat pour dire ah bah
tiens regardez on sait que c'est des
méthodes qui sont très utilisées
notamment les arguments qui ont été mis
en avant ces arguments qui sont
récurrents le fait que les pyromènes
c'était déjà utilisé en Australie en
2019 et en 2020 au moment des mégafeux
parce que je veux dire on en a parlé on
en a parlé à Public Sénat donc sa
légitime le propos d'une certaine façon
c'est systématique on sait qu'on a vu
même des enquêtes assez récentes sur le
fait que je pense ici par exemple aux
enquêtes de Forbin stories qui avait
travaillé à montrer que un journaliste
de BFMTV passer la nuit certains
contenus qui étaient volontairement
poussé par en l'occurrence des pays
étrangers pour que ce soit ensuite
découpé et repris plus tard sans doute
mentionnés que ça passait la nuit entre
deux heures et 4h du matin sur BFM TV
donc en fait travail là là dans ce cadre
là il peut être involontaire même
parfois ils font encore plus loin en
construisant l'information dès le début
frais de courant est-ce qu'il y a une
climato dédialisme de confort
c'est-à-dire on est dans cette dans
cette croyance disons ça pour ne pas
changer sans doute mais là je sais pas
si vous à travers Victor votre étude
vous arrivez aussi ce sera intéressant
de voir politiquement comment ça se
situe bon on va parler franchement vous
savez très bien quand vous regardez
cnews vous avez un public extrêmement
conservateur et je pense que les
journalistes certains du moins de cnews
leur servent particulièrement bien la
soupe on ne touche à rien il faut rien
il faut rien changer surtout pas parce
que ça dérange absolument tout le monde
je peux faire une petite remarque sur la
question que vous aviez fait
l'utilisation peut-être d'un passage de
de ce que vous dites sur Public Sénat
nous on l'a vécu sur l'esprit sorcier TV
on fait régulièrement des des gros
dossiers scientifiques assez complets à
la façon de C'est pas sorcier un peu
avec des animations on avait fait une
animation sur les femmes paramètres de
Milankovich c'était c'est un astronome
et un géophysicien cerveau au 20e siècle
qui et ses repris par toute la science
en fait c'est la position de la Terre et
son inclinaison par rapport au soleil
elle change mais elle change en l'espace
de 10000 ans etc par exemple juste un
exemple la terre elle tourne pas comme
ça parfaitement régulièrement autour du
soleil elle fait une ellipse donc elle
s'éloigne par moment quant à s'éloigne
forcément elle subit moins la chaleur du
soleil donc tout ça ça explique les
grands phénomènes de de de de climat en
fait du passé c'est à dire les périodes
glaciaires interglaciaires etc mais
c'est repris nous ils nous ont piqué
l'animation ils l'ont balancé sur les
réseaux sociaux en disant bah vous voyez
bien l'esprit sorcier est en train de
dire que si un réchauffement climatique
c'est parce que il y a ces cycles
naturels alors que c'était pas du tout
notre propos donc mé
on va je veux bien ce que vous disiez
essayons de mieux comprendre et de mieux
définir vous êtes vous avez fait une
sorte de carte de ceux qui
de ceux qui parlent du climat c'est ça
on pourrait tous les personnes
en France alors on va regarder cette
carte et vous allez nous l'expliquer je
vais essayer alors parce que elle peut
sembler complexe on peut la même bête
pour la pleine écran pour un peu
comprendre ce qu'on regarde ici il faut
savoir que chaque point c'est un
utilisateur un utilisateur de Twitter OK
et deux utilisateurs qui sont reliés si
ils se retweet et donc s'il partage les
mêmes contenus et en fait ce qu'on
observe qu'on fait ce genre de
cartographie c'est qu'on a des grandes
zones de l'espace idéologique qui sont
occupés par des acteurs différents
typiquement vous pouvez voir qu'à droite
on a une grande communauté de
dénialistes et c'est pour ça aussi que
vous comprenez pourquoi quand on est une
information qui commence à se propager
elle va se propager principalement dans
cette communauté là dans ce cercle
beaucoup de mal à sauter à gauche mais
surtout nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
inversement quand vous voyez le GIEC qui
est tout qui donc qui va être relié par
les médias qui sont juste à côté ou par
la communauté qui est proclimat vous
voyez qu'il y a très peu de liens avec
cette communauté d'analystes et donc le
GIEC va avoir beaucoup de mal à toucher
ses communautés de même on peut voir que
juste au dessus on a le gouvernement et
en fait on peut voir que le gouvernement
a des liens avec les médias et avec le
GIEC mais pas tant que ça et ça c'est
des pistes pour expliquer aussi le
manque d'action c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
on a aujourd'hui tout un tas de
communautés qui vont se structurer qui
vont réussir à parler entre eux sans
souci dans leur chambre déco mais qui
vont avoir beaucoup de mal à discuter
entre elles y compris quand ils sont
d'accord notamment sur le côté pro
climat donc ça c'est typiquement le type
d'analyse qu'on propose à l'Institut des
systèmes complexes et en fait on va
essayer de relier ça ensuite avec des
questions politiques et c'est pour ça
que je rebondis sur ce que disait ce que
sur ce que disait freine dit en fait ces
gens-là se réinscrit aussi dans un
paysage politique par exemple on sait
que les dédialistes sont plutôt
anti-systèmes on sait que politiquement
par exemple qui ont plutôt relier des
personnes comme haslino comme Philippot
des gens qui sont en marche qui serait
plutôt de droite alternative quand le
paysage politique Mathieu
une interrogation sur un terme
technosolué la même question donc merci
Mathieu c'est quoi les technosols alors
justement
les technoolutionnistes c'est quoi c'est
une idée selon laquelle la technologie
va être la principale le principal
moteur pour résoudre la crise climatique
va nous sauver quoi exactement la
science de nous sauver et comme vous
pouvez le voir en fait entre les médias
et les dédiéalistes un peu à côté parce
que sur certains sujets on pourra être
repris notamment quand il y a un
alignement mais en parallèle c'est quand
même des gens qui sont tout à fait
d'accord avec les conclusions du rapport
du GIEC là où ça va différé sur les
solutions il faut il faut quand même
frais de courant parler de celles et
ceux qui alors qui sont là à gauche de
votre de votre carte celle qui informe
sur la réalité du réchauffement
climatique par exemple je pense à
l'association la fresque du climat ils
ont formé un million de personnes plus
une un million de personnes en France
est-ce que enfin voilà c'est c'est
est-ce que c'est un une sorte de de de
de combat entre deux entre se passe
alors là vous venez nous expliquer que
ça communiquait pas suffisamment mais
est-ce que le discours de ceux qui ont
été formés peut contrer le discours du
déni d'une certaine façon
parce que en fait là où ça se propage la
mauvaise la fausse information c'est sur
les réseaux sociaux quand vous
rencontrez des gens les personnes qui
s'occupent de la fresque du climat par
exemple il rencontre des jeunes des
gamins etc et tout ils sont en contact
direct avec eux il y a un lien de
confiance qui se crée mais ce déni là
dans ton parle il circule il essaye de
semer le trouble sur les réseaux sociaux
et je suis pas sûr en plus que les
personnes les scientifiques qui sont
objectifs j'allais dire on peut utiliser
le mot sur soit les meilleures
communicants ils réfléchissent pas à ça
ils passent pas leur temps à se dire il
faut à tout prix convaincre alors que
voilà donc il y a malgré tout un
déséquilibre on disait à un moment donné
je sais pas si c'est toujours le cas
mais que une fausse information se
répand beaucoup plus vite six fois plus
vite six fois plus vite qu'une
information
donc des résultats il y a quelques
années c'est encore vrai c'est encore
vrai moi je vais nuancer ça c'est vrai
dans certaines communautés ça il faut
pas croire que si on met une fausse
information n'importe où elle va se
propager beaucoup plus vite en fait
c'est vrai parce que les fausses
informations se propagent dans certaines
communautés et là on a pu le voir on a
une bulle de filtre on a une chambre
déco un groupe restreint et donc ça va
se protéger beaucoup plus vite dans
cette communauté dans ce groupe et donc
en fait la partie qui est dangereuse
mais qui est aussi parfois la solution
c'est le moment des communautés vont se
lier vont se regrouper et là on va voir
la mise en contact on se demande chaque
fois qui va gagner en termes de narratif
allez on se pose la question des des
politiques Mathieu est-ce qu'il y a
encore des climatosceptiques je vais
employer ce terme-là dans la classe
politique
des figures nationales ou c'est une
espèce en voie d'extinction faut quand
même bien le dire l'hiver 2018
Jean-Marie Le Pen pouvait encore Twitter
en scale les miches ceux qui dénonce le
réchauffement climatique sont désespérés
j'ai pas trouvé grand chose depuis parce
qu'on s'était 2023 bah plus grand monde
dans la classe politique n'ose contester
eau et fort le dérèglement climatique
c'est cause comme ces conséquences en
fait le consensus scientifique est
devenu d'une certaine façon un consensus
politique relatif je dis relatif parce
que les débats existent et vous l'avez
souligné sur les moyens de ralentir le
réchauffement de la planète ou sur le
rythme que l'on se fixe pour y parvenir
mais plus personne ne débat de la
nécessité de s'y atteler d'une certaine
façon au contraire j'ai envie de dire
c'est même devenu un incontournable ou
c'est presque impossible vous n'avez pas
un discours de ministre pas un programme
de candidat pas une inauguration un
colloque de partie qui ne sous sont la
désormais traditionnelle référence au
péril du réchauffement climatique il
faut dire que les effets se disent on en
a parlé désormais dans le ciel comme
dans le paysage année après année au fil
des saisons des catastrophes naturelles
il y a un principe de réalité en fait
qui a fini par s'imposer et pourtant il
y a on s'en souvient il y a eu des
controverses majeurs il y a pas si
longtemps que ça une quinzaine d'années
parce que c'était il y a pas si
longtemps que ça le climato scepticisme
ou la républer les clims manipulateurs
c'est à vos amis le climato scepticisme
en politique fut incarné par un homme il
faut quand même lui de gauche Claude à
l'air il faut quand même le dire membre
du PS meilleure amie de Lionel Jospin ce
géophysicien multi récompensé dans sa
discipline je précise bien avec un
invité médaille d'or du CNRS il y avait
le prix confort ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale au discours vous
en souvenez aussi ruptif qui expéditive
dégraisser le fameux mammouth à son
arrivée rue de Grenelle mais il s'est
lancé dans une véritable croisade
climato-sceptique au milieu des années
90 alors que lors de la parution du
premier rapport du GIEC il était plutôt
à ligne qu'est-ce qu'il écrit que c'est
une fausse à l'air au moment de la
publication du deuxième rapport du GIEC
il conteste un danger imaginaire inventé
par des lobbies écologistes il s'appuie
sur son CV de scientifique dans le
climat était pourtant pas l'expertise je
l'ai dit pour contester l'origine
humaine du réchauffement climatique
ensuite il y a même publié un livre qui
s'appelle l'imposture climatique qui a
eu quand même un grand écho c'est un
provocateur pour fendeur du principe de
précaution il devient la bête noire des
écolos il avait traité Nicolas Hulot
d'imbécile et de nul complet et ça
devient une star à droite il finira
d'ailleurs par voter UMP selon son
propre AE toute chose égale par ailleurs
pour pour que nos jeunes téléspectateurs
comprennent je trouve c'était un peu le
professeur Raoul du climat à l'époque
c'est elle faut aduler par des fans et
puis très très contesté ultra contesté
par la communauté scientifique
spécialiste du climat
va durer en gros jusqu'en 2010 c'est là
où on sent un problème bascule et
qu'est-ce qui se passe en 2010 et la
mise de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche de l'époque une certaine
Valérie Pécresse est saisie par un
nombre de scientifiques qui n'en peuvent
plus de de cette controverse et qui
peuvent aller répécresse elle transmet
le dossier à l'Académie des Sciences en
lui demandant de trancher et là il y a
une position à l'unanimité qui est un
véritable camouflet pour Claude Allaire
parce que qui valide à peu près toutes
les toutes les thèses et toutes les
explications on va pas dire les thèses
parce que des grandes vitesses c'est
compliqué tous les faits et tout toutes
les vérifications présentées par le GECK
ce qui sonnera d'une certaine façon la
fin du climato-scepticisme sur la scène
politique
tout à l'heure que les politiques
étaient finalement moins formés ou moins
informés de la réalité du réchauffement
climatique pour autant il n'ose même
s'ils ont des doutes ils osent moins les
exprimer c'est ce que nous dit Mathieu
il y a des problèmes différents il y a
effectivement la question du consensus
politique qui fait d'ailleurs douter
parce que tous d'accord c'est un peu
louche et donc on rentre effectivement
dans ce mythe du complot maintenant on a
quand même des discours politiques assez
surprenant au plus haut niveau de l'État
dans tous les parties on a en fait des
chercheurs qui ont travaillé sur ce
qu'on appelle les arguments du déni on a
même fait des bingo et on peut et c'est
très c'est très triste en fait on peut
tout cocher par exemple la France c'est
que 1% des émissions
et puis non mais c'est bon nous en
France on a pas de problème avec les
énergies fossiles parce que on a du
nucléaire donc notre énergie et des
carbonée on confond le mix électrique et
le mix énergétique mais c'est pas grave
en France il y a plein d'eau parce que
l'hiver il va pleuvoir plus donc il y a
pas de problème par rapport à la
ressource en eau et puis de toute façon
c'est toujours adapté alors
effectivement on voit selon les partis
politiques et il y a eu des articles
d'ailleurs dans des journaux nationaux
qui effectivement démontre comment chez
les dans certains partis on va pas
forcément douter du changement
climatique mais on va quand même
expliquer que c'est pas si clair que ça
qu'on sait pas bien qu'on sait pas trop
c'est aussi beaucoup de démagogie c'est
parfois du mensonge comment voulez-vous
qu'en chercheur alors je suis d'accord
les chercheurs parfois ils s'expriment
je rappelle juste que c'est pas leur
métier s'ils ont choisi de chercher
c'est pour faire progresser les
connaissances voilà et puis plutôt qu'à
d'aller comme on le fait beaucoup et
peut-être trop sur les plateaux télé il
faut aussi qu'on continue à travailler
dans nos domaines de recherche et c'est
pas facile mais imaginez quand vous avez
un grand élu politique un chef de partie
quand vous avez un grand média on a
encore eu des journaux qui ont fait des
pleines pages sur des climato-sceptiques
qu'est-ce que nous chercheurs on peut
faire quand vous avez quelqu'un qui a
une audience de 5 6 7 millions de
téléspectateurs je suis avec nos pauvres
réseaux sociaux qui sont les grandes
figures pour vous climato-sceptiques
aujourd'hui
ce soit dans le domaine intellectuel de
la recherche ou un politique les gens
qu'on entend et qui contestent le
réchauffement enfin le dérèglement
climatique parce que
il y a plusieurs choses parce qu'en
fait et comme ça on va plutôt attaquer
les chercheurs avec par exemple des
termes autour de du militantisme du vous
êtes par exemple moi je suis en tant que
cherche je suis systématiquement
maintenant vendu à l'extrême gauche aux
écologistes et quand j'ai le malheur à
l'inverse de dire mais attention le
gouvernement parce que il y a des choses
qu'on a été faites je suis vendue à
Macron donc en fait tous les jours je
change d'étiquettes politiques en
essayant juste d'expliquer qu'à un
moment donné je ne fais qu'exprimer les
fier pleine page ou des grandes
interviews un grand quotidien national a
consacré une interview entière à
personnalité et je ne ferai pas la
publicité pour cette personne qui nie
effectivement le changement climatique
explique que ce n'est pas si clair avec
une publicité pleine page dans ce
journal plein de pages dans ce journal
on a sur des chaînes de service public
des
chercheurs qui arrivent et qui vont
expliquer que par exemple la France est
que politique dont vous parlez c'est top
alors c'est pas une personnalité
politique mais on va aussi avoir des
relais sur des personnalités politiques
c'est celui qui a écrit le livre dont on
parler tout à l'heure qui attaquent le
GIEC
on va finir par lui faire une pub de
dingue parce que tout le monde va
chercher comment il s'appelle
effectivement certains dérapages
politiques notamment par exemple on en a
eu beaucoup au moment des bassines on en
a eu beaucoup au moment des dans des
situations de conflit où on arrive et
alors sur le cadre degrés c'était
magnifique hein quand Christophe Béchu
annonce ce qui est une vraie victoire de
dire il faut préparer la France la plus
4 degrés on a eu d'un côté ah mais il
renonce à l'atténuation ce qui est
complètement faux et en face d'autres
ténors de parti politique du bord
inverse qui disait ah bah c'est super il
a bien démontré qu'il suffisait pas
d'atténuer il faut s'adapter si vous
voulez on est quand même dans des choses
où les scientifiques de ce pays ne sont
pas respectés alors moi je vais je vais
donner un nom de politique et je me
tourne vers vous est-ce que par exemple
Éric Zemmour et celui dans les parce que
vous hésitez à ce niveau etc bon dans
ceux qui ont un poids national il a fait
7 % de la présidentielle qui flirt le
plus avec ses idées là peut-être pour
caresser son son électorat dans le sens
du sens du déni quoi alors je dirais que
ça ça ça va plutôt dans l'autre sens
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il va pas
forcément flirter volontairement mais il
va pas forcément fermer la porte en
parallèle d'accord pourquoi parce qu'en
fait il sait qu'il y a une communauté
qui va être plutôt anti-système qui va
potentiellement le lieu de sympathique
mais il va savoir jouer avec la limite
et globalement c'est beaucoup plus cette
communauté là va beaucoup plus se
rapprocher de lui par opportunisme plus
que par conviction c'est que c'est des
gens qui vont ne pas trouver une réponse
ou une audience à leur sujet dans le
paysage critique donc ils vont
probablement choisir la personne qui
sont approche le plus donc je pense que
la dynamique est plutôt inverse on a une
dynamique anti-système qui existe en
ligne et qui est réel elle va se
rabattre sur le candidat qui est
probablement le moins loin de ses idées
sans forcément que ce soit volontaire en
face du côté des sous-texte il peut s'en
prendre au délire des écologistes comme
il dit et tout le monde va comprendre ou
traduire ça par ceux qui souhaitent
alors je vous propose une passe d'armes
finalement assez récente puisqu'elle
date de la dernière élection
présidentielle dernière campagne on va
écouter d'abord Emmanuel Macron et
ensuite Marine Le Pen Emmanuel uel
Macron qui pointe le climatocepticisme
de la candidate du rassemblement
national c'était lors de du meeting
d'Emmanuel Macron d'entre deux tours à
Marseille
le choix est clair aujourd'hui
l'extrême droite est un projet
climato-sceptique un projet qui veut
sortir des ambitions actuelles de
l'Europe du climat
qui veut détruire les éoliennes l'un des
seuls projets de cette campagne qui n'y
croient pas nous nous y croyons et nous
nous le ferons et la candidate du
rassemblement national elle lui répond à
quel moment dans le débat d'entre-deux
tours je suis absolument pas
climato-sceptique
en aucun cas mais vous vous êtes un peu
climato hypocrite d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être pour ça que les gens ne
croient pas à votre volonté de régler
tous ces problèmes là et je vais vous
dire pourquoi ils ont raison d'ailleurs
c'est que vous êtes en même temps le
pire de l'écologie punitive vous avez
accompagné des choses qui sont d'une
grande violence pour les classes
moyennes pour les classes modestes de
nos compatriotes
Magli à ce discours là ces mots écologie
punitive on l'a entendu dans les
discours de beaucoup de politiques pas
seulement à l'extrême droite d'ailleurs
bah oui oui merci de le rappeler on est
bien d'accord est-ce que c'est un
argument là aussi pour retarder les
décisions important es si on parle de la
responsabilité de chez vous donner un
fait en 7 ans 16000 personnes en France
sont mortes tes vagues de chaleur
16000 personnes en France sur les sept
dernières années sont mortes vagues de
chaleur qui ont été attribués au
changement climatique et qui n'auraient
pas eu lieu ou pas à cette ampleur là
dans un climat non réchauffé par l'homme
voilà c'est tout vous donner des faits
frais de courant parce que quand
j'entends écologie punitive je pense à
un discours qui est de plus en plus tenu
sur le fait de rendre la transformation
environnementale désirable donc c'est un
peu l'antithèse utilisé la culture le
cinéma des romans pourquoi pas la
publicité aussi pour créer un imaginaire
qui soit pas le l'imaginaire classique
j'allais dire du cowboy ou du ou du
conducteur avec une grosse voiture qui
qui roule au diesel je vais me faire
plein d'amis en disant ça qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez de ça du rôle de la
culture du rôle de l'imaginaire dans le
débat qu'on a aujourd'hui quand il faut
contrer ceux qui sont dans le déni
est-ce que c'est un levier pour vous ah
oui c'est un levier alors moi je pense
surtout j'ai vu une expérience il y a
pas très longtemps on faisait une
opération au Pont du Gard le week-end
dernier sur la prévention des risques
naturels et il y avait plein d'enfants
et il y avait un metteur en scène avec
une troupe de théâtre qui faisait la
prévention là-dessus et qui abordait les
questions du changement climatique et
qu'il l'abordait pas du tout d'une façon
anxiogène en plus mais qui allait direct
qui parlait franchement et derrière il y
a un débat entre les comédiens les
jeunes et tout c'est redoutablement
efficace ça marche il faut je sais pas
je réponds répondez parfaitement à la
question mais par rapport à un public
jeune oui oui ça marche il y a autre
chose quand on parle des politiques
alors effectivement vous disiez tout à
l'heure il y a pas il y en a pas un qui
s'affiche climato-sceptique aujourd'hui
mais d'abord un d'accord mais est-ce que
un ils agissent et de est-ce qu'ils
connaissent est-ce qu'ils ont une un
minimum de culture scientifique
là-dessus qui est devrait être de la
culture générale d'ailleurs pour exclure
personne quand Valérie Masson Delmotte
avait fait la formation au gouvernement
et a fait la formation devant
l'Assemblée nationale des députés
mais leur niveau on a constaté il était
donc c'est bien qu'ils aient fait cet
effort mais il y a aucune culture
là-dessus de façon générale il y a
aucune culture scientifique est-ce qu'il
faut les deux armes c'est à dire que
vous vous avez en donnant des faits sur
la mortalité liée au vagues de chaleur
on va vous dire vous êtes dans
l'anxiogène
il faut il faut savoir dire ça il faut
savoir dire ça et en même temps créer un
nouvel imaginaire vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est que quand on lit le
rapport du GIEC alors personne ne lit
mais quand on lit le résumé au décideur
c'est plus c'est plus vrai en fait on
voit que toutes les solutions
aujourd'hui d'atténuation et
d'adaptation existent et qu'elles
apportent des co bénéfices on va
approcher de la période estivale c'est
le moment des régimes certes on peut se
dire que le régime c'est une période de
sang et de l'art mais que on va mal
manger etc mais les gens qui ont
vraiment des problèmes par rapport à
leur poids apprendre à bien manger à
prendre à retrouver le goût des aliments
à prendre à retrouver du temps avec ses
proches apprendre à travailler ensemble
à prendre à se parler avant une
meilleure santé mais quand on parle
comme ça en fait c'est pas un régime
c'est de réapprendre à bien manger et ce
discours là il est audible et on a
arrêté effectivement les régimes secs et
ben c'est pareil pour le climat on a
aujourd'hui des solutions qui nous
permettent de mieux vivre réellement
c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est la
science qui démontre que derrière c'est
du meilleur logement c'est une meilleure
alimentation c'est une meilleure santé
c'est une meilleure qualité de vie au
travail c'est une meilleure éducation
tout en fait qui aujourd'hui préoccupe
les Français y compris le pouvoir
d'achat y compris le pouvoir d'achat
dans un monde décarboné correctement
avec une adaptation qui permet d'être de
vivre en sécurité et bien notre pouvoir
d'achat il est stabilisé parce
qu'effectivement on va réorienter nos
dépenses et on pourra toujours accéder à
ce qui pour nous est essentiel
rappelez-vous pendant le covid dernier
mot les biens essentiels c'était les
livres
rappelez-vous de ça merci à tous on va
terminer sur cette burn et belle pensée
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat qui
était passionnant je vous dis à bientôt
sur sur Public Sénat et je vous dis à
toutes et à tous merci de votre fidélité
et à demain pour un nouveau numéro de
sciences publiques vous pouvez également
nous retrouver sur la plateforme public
sénat.fr ainsi que tous les programmes
de la chaîne notez que demain dans sa
matinale Oriane Mancini reçoit à
calgarido la députée elle est fille de
scène Saint-Denis belle soirée
[Musique]